ご視聴ありがとうございました Ein Wuhu! Herzlich willkommen! Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,, wir steigen heute in der Mitte ein, am Höhepunkt steigen wir schon direkt ein, schon dass ihr da seid zur neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. Das Podcast UFO mit Florentin Will und Best Boy und Gaffer in Personalunion heute, Stefan Tietze, mir gegenüber. Ja, wir haben eine Brandmail bekommen, quasi, glaube ich, kann man sagen. Was? Zum Intro jetzt? Zum Intro jetzt, genau, wir haben eine Brandmail bekommen, und zwar, wo ist Klaus Badelt? Ja, wir warten, warten, warten. Die Community sitzt da, dreht die Daumen, wippt mit den Knien und wartet jede Folge erneut, schaltet volle Hoffnung ein und wird erneut ins Gesicht geschlagen. Klaus Badelt ist abwesend. Er fehlt. Klaus Badelt ist fehlt. Eingefroren. Ist wahrscheinlich eingefroren. Unsere aktuelle Theorie, warum er nicht auf unsere Mails antwortet, ist wahrscheinlich, seine Finger sind schlicht nicht in der Lage, eine Tastatur zu bedienen, weil sie gefroren sind. Ja, meine letzte Mail, ich will nicht zu viel jetzt natürlich so in Internetprozesse geben, und so sind ja auch viele private Korrespondenzen, aber der Betreff, den kann ich verraten, eingefroren, Fragezeichen, stell von Tietze an klausbadl.com. F, W, D, F, W, D, Re, Re, Re, Re, eingefroren, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Re, Re, Re, Re, Re, eingefroren, Intro. Immer noch eingefroren. Eingefroren, x Intro. Und zum Glück hat jemand gesagt, nein, ich nehme den Dirigierstock selbst in die Hand und hau einfach mal ein episches John-Williams-eskes Intro raus. Es ist Sebastian. Also statt Klaus Badelt haben wir jetzt Sebastian, der uns in diese Folge hineinwirft. Tini Sendaia ohne Nachnamen. Absolut, nur Sebastian. Ich finde, manche Namen, da kannst du das machen, diesen One-Name-Pony, nenne ich es mal einfach. Also sowas wie Sendaia oder Madonna. Ja, Cher, klar. Das geht, Cher. Aber es muss eine spezielle Art Name sein. Richtig. Also Stefan, blank, also stell dir mal vor, so ein Denis Villeneuve-Film, und dann hast du die ganzen Namen, so Javier Bardem, Zendaya, Timothy Chalamet, Stefan. Ja, ja. Einfach ohne Nachnamen. Ja, es funktioniert nicht. Bei Stefan denkst du an Mitbewohner. So, und bei Sebastian denke ich an Kommilitonen. So, und ich hab jetzt noch nicht dieses dieses Sendaya-Flair irgendwie mit drin. Aber ich muss auch sagen, ich finde, entweder du hast drei Namen oder einen. Zwei finde ich eher so lame. Also entweder du heisst Wolfgang M. Schmidt oder du heisst Cher. So, das sind die beiden Welten, die es gibt. Und ich finde, wer ist genau richtig? Samuel L. Jackson. Richtig. Oder fucking Marad Meyer Landrut, die erst Lena Meyer Landrut hieß und dann aber gesagt, nee, ich heiße nur Lena, von drei zu eins, du hast die zwei übergangen. Nein, aber da tritt jetzt wiederum Gesetz eins in Kraft, was wir zu Anfang gerade gesagt hatten. Der Name muss speziell sein. Bei Lena habe ich das Stefan-Problem. Lena ist zu, weil bei Nena wiederum funktioniert es super. Stimmt, ja. Lena funktioniert. Ist irgendwie so mega iconic. Heisst Nena Nena oder ist es ein Künstlername wie Falco? Falco heißt nicht Falco, oder? Wie heißt der Nena mit Nachnamen? Ach ja, gut, jetzt kommen wieder die, ich habe alle Chartshows gesehen, ich habe die Hits gesehen, Antenne Bayern, Antenne Radio. Weiß ich nicht, ich kann mich da rausfusschicken, aber dann stand die Frage dann doch noch im Raum. Ich habe gedacht, ich gebe der Frage kurz Zeit, den Raum zu verlassen, aber dann war sie doch noch da. Sie steht noch sehr, sehr präsent im Raum. Wie heißt Nena eigentlich? Ich glaube, sie heißt in Wahrheit wahrscheinlich Vanessa. Kann auch sein, ja, oder es ist so wie Harpe, so Nena, so Nele Natalie, und es wird aber abgekürzt zu Nena, kann auch sein. Aber guck mal, Nena funktioniert, Lena funktioniert nicht. Lena May-Landrut, LML funktioniert super. Ich finde Lena funktioniert ... Westenhagen super. Marius Müller-Westenhagen, sorry, sorry. Lass mich nur meinen Punkt machen. So. Ich finde, Lena funktioniert deswegen, weil man schon lange Lena Meyer-Landrut kannte in der Öffentlichkeit. Wäre sie aufgetreten als Hier bin ich, hier ist Lena, absoluter Flop. Satellite hätte es nie gegeben, der Mensch hätte den Weltraum nie erobert, vergiss es. Aber wenn man lange als Lena Meierlandruder in der Öffentlichkeit steht, im Brandlicht der Öffentlichkeit und dann aber sagt, ich gehe zurück zu Lena, dann geht's. Weil alle haben ja, ich stelle mir so eine große Lupe vor und Lena ist so eine kleine Ameise, die davon rennt und dann irgendwann aber sagt, nein, ich renne nicht länger davon, ich stelle mich ins Brennlicht und heisst Lena. Und bisher steht sie nicht in Flammen. Wollte ich nur mal sagen. Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie aktuell, ich weiß nicht, ob der Trend vom Einfrieren in Flammen stehen geht, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Ich finde es gut, dass sie sich so nennt, ich möchte nur anmerken, aber gut, wer sind wir? Aber Namensvorschläge, geh wieder zurück auf Lena Meyer-Landrut. Okay, oder nur Meyer-Landrut. Meyer ist ja auch ein schöner Vorname, kannst ja auch immer nehmen. Aber hast du, ich kann einen Film oft nicht genießen, wenn Leute brennen. Weil ich oft so sehr diesen Bavaria-Filmstudios, Typ hat so einen riesen dicken Anorak an. Und in der Sekunde, in der er weggeschnitten wird, weiß man, es kommen vier Leute mit Decken und Feuerlöschern und hauen ihn um und wird direkt umgetreten und wirklich über die Schulle geworfen, damit man ihn möglichst gut löschen kann. Es gibt manche Special Effects, wo man jetzt inzwischen schon zu viel Behind-the-Scenes-Videos gesehen hat, dass sie nicht mehr funktionieren. Und da möchte ich noch mal was sagen. Auch so was wie die neue Herr-der-Ringe-Serie, unabhängig davon, dass es auch inhaltlich kompletter Trash ist, ist es auch die Umsetzung kompletter Trash, weil, und da waren bestimmt skilled Leute am Start, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, dass man diese ganze, diese Hohlkehlentechnik, die auch bei Mandalorian eingesetzt wurde, um quasi auf Serienbudget immer noch tolle neue Welten zu erzählen. Diese Greenscreen-Sätze hinter den Grund, ja, aber nur für den Laien. Genau, aber du hast im Hintergrund wirklich ... CGI im weitesten Sinne. Du hast wie Fernseher im Hintergrund die Projektion quasi und dadurch auch natürlicher aussehen soll als Greenscreen, weil die Beleuchtung natürlich trotzdem irgendwie der der Umgebung entspricht.
und irgendwie, dann weiss ich nicht, ob man das so oft gesehen hat, deswegen weiss ich immer noch, dass die dann einfach so drei Steine in diese, weil das dann so, sagen wir mal so 20 Quadratmeter Platz immer in diesem Kreis, wo hinten wurde dann mit Unreal Engine wurde dann halt so eine so ein Planet programmiert und dann vornherein schnittst du da so ein bisschen Sand auf, legst dann so drei Steine hin, wie ich für meinen Kampffisch, Jeff. Ja. Und dann spielen die da. Und dann sieht es zwar so ein bisschen so aus wie ein Planet, aber irgendwie auch nicht, weil die sich mega eindrug wunderbar, was für eine geile neue Technik das ist. Ich hab das Gefühl, ich sehe das den Serien an, dass sie alle nur auf diesem kleinen Raum spielen. Weil natürlich, die gehen keine Wege. Die gehen keine Wege, die rennen nicht einfach mal durch die Gegend. Die rennen nicht mehr von A nach B. Sondern die gehen vielleicht mal zwei Schritte nach vorne und interagieren mit der einen Requisite, die tatsächlich echt ist. Die man schon manchmal so, wie bei diesen Zeichentricksachen, wie bei Spongebob, wo man die immer schon gesehen hat. Richtig, genau. Weilzeichnet sind. Genau, und du weißt, dieser Grashalm, der bewegt sich leicht, da passiert was. Und jetzt denkt man an Herr der Ringe, die Filme, auch dass wir schon wieder darüber reden. Ja, da nicht. Ich habe mich letztens gefragt, als Frodo und Sam das Auenland verlassen, da sagt er ja, okay, jetzt gehe ich einen Schritt und bin weiter weg als je zuvor. Ja, haben wir vor zwei Wochen drüber gesagt. Pass auf, pass auf. Jetzt geht's noch weiter, dann kommt Bre. Wir kommen auch nicht voran. Wir reden immer noch über die gleichen Filme, aber nicht nur das, sondern auch über die gleichen Stellen. Wir haben ein episches Intro bekommen, da ist Herr der Ringe völlig richtig. Und zwar, dann kommt ja noch Bre, dann kommt die Wetterspitze. Ja, ganz viel Zeug. Dann wird Frodo von der Morgul-Klinge gestichen.
Oh nein, er ist vergiftet, nur die Heilmagie Elrons kann ihn retten.
Aber bis dahin müssen wir zurück. Königskraut schafft das noch ein bisschen.
Königskraut zögert das noch ein bisschen raus.
Aragorn, der Waldläufer, kennt natürlich Königskraut,
kennt sich aus im Wald und sagt, ja, das sieht so und so aus, Sam, kennst du das?
Und Sam sagt, ja, das wächst hier überall.
Und da dachte ich erst, okay, cool, weil Sam ist ja Gärtner, der kennt sich ja aus mit Pflanzen. Aber stopp, der kennt sich ja da vor Ort überhaupt nicht aus. Der ist ja weit aus seiner Comfortzone, der ist ja ganz weit raus, wo er sich überhaupt nicht kennt, wo er die Flora überhaupt nicht kennt. Ja, aber er ist ja da lang gelaufen. Und dann sagt er, ja, aber nee, das akzeptiere ich nicht. Also du vergisst ja, dass die schon zwei Wochen laufen zum Zeitpunkt. Aber es ist erst stockdunkel, Wetterspitze stockdunkel, die kennen sich da nicht aus. Dann wird Frodo gepackt, von Aragon in irgendeinen Wald getragen und alles. Und dann in der Nacht sagt er, nee, ich finde hier Königskraut, finde ich, also ein paar Pro-Argumente erst mal. Ich finde gut, dass Sam das sagt, weil er der Gärtner ist. Ich finde erst auch zweitens gut übersetzt, weil im Englischen sagt er, it's a weed. Und im Deutschen sagt er, das wächst überall. Ich find das gut übersetzt. Ich mag es für die Übersetzungen nicht genau versuchen zu treffen und sagen, das wächst wie Unkraut. Das ist eine Gras-Sorte. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, das eben nicht. Nee, nee, das, so, okay. Ich, wie anders Herr der Ringe sein könnte, wenn du den Film übersetzt hättest, wir sässen heute nicht hier, wenn Stefan Tee zur Übersetzung Stefan, da hätte man schon merken sollen, dass es kein guter Film ist. Aber ganz kurz, ey, erstens war das ein Scherz, Das ist nicht die richtige Zeit und nicht der richtige Ort, mir scherzen zu. Du triffst mich da jetzt an einen wunden Punkt, weil ich behaupte, dass ich es besser könnte, als viele andere diesen Job machen. Ja, okay. Aber wiederum, wenn man sich das erste Mal hinsetzt, das erste Mal, dann würde das so dann in Krüger-mäßig, würde man direkt merken, ah ne, man ist doch nicht besser als ...
Er hat gar keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Macht das weiter, er macht alles super.
Vor allem, es muss ja lippensynchron sein.
Und dann musst du halt gucken, und deswegen hätte ich mir da,
finde ich die Szene unrealistisch.
Ich habe einen Thread aufgemacht im Filmfehlerforum,
dass das ein Filmfehler ist, das Sam eigentlich gar nicht
wissen sollte. Und es passt auch nicht zum
Charakter von Sam, dass er sofort
so super souverän sagt, ach ja klar, es wächst überall,
kein Problem, ich war hier noch nie. So, gib mir nicht die Szene, oh, ich bin so weit weg von der Heimat, ich hab Angst, ich kenn mich nicht aus, und gib mir dann 20 Minuten später die Szene, ja klar, es wächst überall, überhaupt kein Problem, hol ich. Ich hätte mir eher sowas gewünscht wie ... Eine Szene, wo er sagt, oh Königstraut, oh Königstraut, oh Königstraut, das wächst ja überall. Und dann, tüffelt er uns später, jetzt haben wir die Szene gesehen. Genau, Königstraut, und das Königstraut ist immer schon so anders animiert, was man schon wie bei Spudsch. So beleuchtet, so offensichtlich ist es so a thing, was noch auftaucht, so Chekhov's Gun. Entweder das oder Sam sagt, hey, such Königskraut, kennst du das, dann sagt er, pass auf, ich habe zu Hause meinen Garten, ich kenne diverse Kräuter, ich habe hier Margritten, verschiedene unterschiedliche Dinge, aber ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob das hier auch wächst. Ich probiere mein Bestes, ich komme zurück, falls ich es finde und dann geht er weg.
Oder einfach, er sagt einfach, ah ja, kenne ich. Keine Fragen, wahrscheinlich immer noch geil erklärt, weil er ist Gärtner, wahrscheinlich kennt er viele Pflanzensorten und wenn diese Welt da so ist ist wie hier, also ich sag mal, so weit wir gegangen sind, da wäre ich von Köln aus ungefähr in Bochum. Da wächst noch grob das gleiche Zeugs. Weißt du ja gar nicht, weißt du nicht, weil du warst ja noch nie in Bochum, du bist ein Lebermann, ein Kosmopolit, du warst schon überall, Brüssel, Paris, du warst ja eben noch nie weiter weg, du hast ja keine Ahnung, wie die Welt da draußen ist. Aber die Welt da sieht nicht grossartig anders aus. Ich will nur sagen... Für einen Gärtner? Ein Gärtner kennt sich ja beim Pflanzen aus. Der hat wahrscheinlich schon mal Bücher gelesen über Pflanzen, die woanders wachsen. Wenn er einfach gesagt hätte, ja, kenne ich, wären keine Fragen gewesen. Immer noch, ah, seine Gärtner-Expertise scheint ihm hier offenbar zu helfen. Ich sag nur so, Peter Jackson, du bist noch nicht raus aus der Sache. Der Thread steht Filmfehlerforum aktiv. Aktuell habe ich noch null Likes. Aber das wird sich ... Für mich liegt Dislikes. Das wird sich schnell ändern, auf jeden Fall. Aber auch so eine Szene, die wahrscheinlich im echten Leben nicht gut funktionieren würde. Man verarzt jemanden, oh Gott, fuck schnell. Sam, lauf los und hol Königskraut. Und ich würde mir als Sam denken, wie lange habe ich Zeit, bis wann, wenn ich gar nichts finde. Ich finde eine Stunde lang nichts. Wann komme ich zurück mit leeren Händen? Geht ihr weiter, verarschtest du ihn hier oder bringst ihn zurück zur Wetterspitze. Genau, nee, wir warten hier auf dich. So, weil dann taucht ja auf Arwen. So, und das weiß ja Sam nicht. Das heißt, es kann gut sein, Sam ist eine Stunde weg, währenddessen kommt Arwen. Oh, Ilunador, die heilige, die weisse Jungfer und so. Und Aragon sagt, cool, dass du da bist. Pass auf, ich habe vor zehn Minuten Sam losgeschickt, um den Königskraut zu suchen. Fümme Geschichte, der ist jetzt weg. Der ist noch nicht da. Sam! Sam! Ja, okay. Ich könnte ihn jetzt zu Elrond bringen. Ich weiß, das ist super. Und du hast ein schnelles Pferd. Genau, ich habe das schnellste Pferd. Asphalot, das ist super. Gott, dass du den... Frodo, pass auf, Frodo, pass auf, wie wichtig ist dir Sam? Lass uns nochmal, weil du meintest, der ist dein Gärtner, oder? Also es ist so, wie du Auftragstung, oder kommt der regelmäßig? Kurz beim Stamm und so, okay, ich, okay, also eher nicht so wichtig. Es sind diese typischen Dinge, diese typischen Film-Tropen, die super funktionieren, weil die gelernt sind. Im echten Leben sind so manche Sachen, die man sagt, auch immer dieses, wir treffen uns da und da, okay, Ecke 45. Bell Street aufgelegt. Wann? Wann? Heute, überhaupt ist heute. Deswegen möchte ich ein anderes Thema aufmachen, was sehr dazu reinspielt, auch gerade zu deinem Königskraut, Gate. Und zwar, erzählte Zeit versus erzählende Zeit. Und das ist in Filmen spannend, und ich finde, bei Herr der Ringe läuft sehr viel, jetzt mal als positiv Beispiel, aber es kann auch ein Stand-in für alle anderen Filme sein, achtet mal drauf, wie viel Zeit vergeht in einem Film, nicht während des Films, die 90 Minuten oder bis drei Stunden, sondern was erzählt die Zeit, was ist die erzählte Zeit und das ist ganz spannend, weil bei Herr der Ringe finde ich das nicht so gut gelungen. Das ist fast eins zu eins eigentlich, ne? Das sind neun, achtzehn Stunden Film. Weil dir kommt es, wenn du die Bücher liest, vor wie, ah, die waren bestimmt vier, fünf Jahre unterwegs, was auch immer, hab ich jetzt nicht genau im Kopf. Da werden wahrscheinlich jetzt Leute, die das, der Buchfest sind, was sagen, aber im Film kommt es mir vor wie sechs Tage. Ja. Und dann denke ich mir, bei jedem Dreck, den Frodo mehr im Gesicht hat, denke ich mir, Bullshit. Du bist sechs Tage unterwegs, du bist sechs Tage und wenn er dann so heim wird zum Auenland, denke ich mir. Ihr seid ja seit einer Woche weg. Und dann hat er so Hunger und ah, Lembersbrot, oh nein, man denkt sich, ich habe Seven vs. Wild gesehen, man kann auch sieben Tage ohne Essen überleben, dieses Cribe. Ich habe Knossi gesehen, wie er am Strand zwar ein bisschen quengelig war, aber nicht so quengelig, Frodo. Also da muss ich schon mal, Frodo, reiss dich zusammen. Nee, es stimmt schon. Es sind schwierige Dinge und da kann ich Filme auch nicht mehr genießen, weil mir solche Dinge auffallen und das Filmphilophorum ist mein bester Freund. Brennende Menschen ist aber ein guter Punkt. Brennende Menschen ... Weil das hat man so oft gesehen, wie das weitergeht. Ja.
Wenn VFX macht Feierabend, wenn die Kamera aus ist. Ich weiss, ich kenne die Frames danach, wie du schon sagst. Da werfen sich Leute mit Decken drauf oder da kommen Feuerlöscher. Und du siehst es fast schon, manchmal schneiden die leider auch ein bisschen zu kurz, dass dann der brennende Ork und dann kommt noch so ein Produktionstyp mit dem Feuerlöscher und dann wird er es weggeschnitten. So, das fände ich eigentlich mal richtig witzig. So ein Cut von einem Film, wo jede Szene so einen Ticken zu lang stehen bleibt. Und dann direkt wieder alle so die Energie fällt ab. So, der legt das Schwert nieder, der zieht den Helm aus. Boah, fuck, ist das heiß. Cut zu ... Dann geht es wieder weiter. Jeder einzelne Bild ein bisschen zu lang. Das finde ich sehr gut. Auch die Musik ist immer ein bisschen zu lang aufgenommen, dass dann schon der Dirigent oder so sagt, danke, jetzt machen wir noch mal, er war am Tag 13. Achtet bitte auf die Sechzehntel, ne? Alles zu spät. Aber das ist mir aufgefallen im Film Civil War. Ja. Wir sind ja beide große Alex Garland-Fans. Heißt der Alex, ich weiß nicht, der von Ex Machina. Ich. Ich liebe ihn. Lieb ich und fand ich ganz toll, Annihilation, auch toller Film. Civil War hat mir gar nicht gefallen, vor allem wegen dem Editing, weil alles stand so ein bisschen zu lang. Man sieht so ein Auto, fährt so durch, da erzählen jemand einen Weg, eine Fahrt, Auto fährt durch, Kamera fährt das Auto so mit, Auto ist weg und dann die Kamera bleibt an.
Und als Live-Regisseur bei Formel 1 würde man wahrscheinlich
dann wegschneiden, die nächste Kamera, wie beim Formel 1-Rennen,
das ist halt der nächste Auto im Bild.
Ich habe da aber Verständnis dafür,
ich habe auch schon einen oder anderen Film geschnitten.
Und es ist so, ich glaube, man kennt das ja,
wenn du einen Aufsatz schreibst und der Lehrer sagt so,
ja, mach so zehn Seiten.
Und du schreibst den Aufsatz und hast acht.
Da denkst du ja, aber alle Leerzeichen werden zu zwei Leerzeichen. Die Schriftgröße mal so einen halben Tacken hoch. Und genau so läuft das beim Film auch. Du drehst, du drehst, du drehst ein Jahr lang, hast das alles im Schnittraum und hast am Ende so gute 65 Minuten. Und der Regisseur sagt, ja Leute, das ist doch kein Film, 65 Minuten
ist nix. Wieso, ist das so lang wie
seinlos? Ja, und dann, ja, dann lass das
nochmal ein bisschen länger stehen,
können wir ein bisschen Slow-Mo, also wenn wir den
ganzen Film so in 1,1
reden alle super viel zu tief, das klingt alles
cool, nee, Batman,
sag mal, das ist
Batman, nee, das ist cool,
das ist cool, das ist Batman, nee, das machen wir. So, und dann mach mal, genau, vorm Film Widmung. Pass auf, wem können wir den Film widmen? War da nicht so ein, da war doch so ein Minenunfall. Da war doch in dem Nachbarort, wo wir gedreht haben, da ist doch so eine Mine eingestürzt. Lass uns alle Minenarbeiter, hol die Liste. Das ... Drachen und Ritter bei uns, es ist mega weird, dass wir am Anfang den Minenleuten danken. Wir müssen irgendwie Zeit ständen, hol die Namen von allen Minenarbeitern und dann machen wir ein Bild, Schwarz-Weiss-Bild, noch bevor der Film losgeht, ein Bild von jedem einzelnen Minenarbeiter, wirklich lass jeden zehn stehen, da sind 120 Leute gestorben, kein Problem, da haben wir gute zehn Minuten raus. Easy, alles klar, macht's gut,
wir sehen uns morgen.
Deswegen plädiere
ich, und ich glaube, ich spreche da auch für dich
mit, dafür, dass
lasst Dinge
so lang sein, wie sie sind.
Ich mache diese
Appelle an unsere Hörerschaft,
wenn ihr ein Hollywood-Blockbuster schneidet,
dann übertreibt es nicht, Leute, wirklich. Aber die Abstraktionsleistung kriegt ihr jetzt auch noch hin, glaube ich. Ja, das kann man im Alltag auch nutzen. Wenn ihr ein Essay schreibt und der ist super, wie der ist, aber der ist halt so 20 Zeichen zu kurz, dann gebt den ab. Seid mutig. Die Zeiten, in denen wir leben, erfordern Mut. Ich möchte, dass ihr da rausgeht und die Dinge, auf die ihr stolz seid, mit denen ihr zufrieden seid, die gebt ihr so ab, wie sie sind, auch wenn es fucking 20 Zeichen. Wenn dann der Lehrer sagt, nee, das ist eine fünf, weil du hast zu wenig Zeichen benutzt, denke ich mir, ja, fuck this guy, von dem wollt ihr keine gute Note. Okay, aber du fällst trotzdem durch. Ja, von dem wollt ihr durch, da wollt ihr dann noch durchfallen.
Okay, du willst die Klasse noch mal machen.
Das ist ein Kurs, okay, wenn das das Opfer von dem wollt ihr durch. Da wollt ihr dann noch durchfallen. Okay, du willst die Klasse noch mal machen.
Das ist ein Kurs.
Okay, wenn das das Opfer ist, was ihr bringen müsst,
ja, dann fucking wiederholt die achte Klasse.
Okay, ja, finde ich gut.
Oder sitzt mal in einem Meeting und sagt nichts.
Wenn ihr nichts zu sagen habt, dann setzt euch hin,
steht wieder auf und geht.
Seid nicht der, der sagt, ja, eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, Fred,
weil du meintest, dass wir noch mal auf die Details schauen müssen.
Das würde ich nämlich auch noch mal gerne sagen,
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. steht wieder auf und geht. Seid nicht der, der sagt, ja, eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, Fred, weil du meintest, dass wir noch mal auf die Details schauen müssen. Das würde ich nämlich auch noch mal gerne sagen, dass die Details super wichtig sind, vor allem in der Abrechnung, weil wir hatten letztes Jahr ja diesen Vorfall, wo dann am Ende die Nullen überall nicht gestimmt waren, gestimmt haben und deswegen, und ich wollte auch noch mal sagen, dass ich es von der Zielsetzung finde, wichtig, dass es präzise ist.
Was hat Annika jetzt schon gesagt auch.
Genau, dass es präzise ist.
Ja, das ist wirklich klare Benchmarks, dass wir die treffen können.
Weil sonst schwimmen wir wieder, wie letztes Jahr.
Letztes Jahr war für mich echt ein absoluter Einfall.
Und deswegen die Benchmarks, kannst du die noch mal durchschicken?
Ja, das haben wir besprochen. Genau, schick sie einfach nochmal durch, damit wir die alle haben und dann ist auch gut. Okay. Vor allem, wir waren neulich in einem Zoom-Call und ich war so stolz auf einen von den Leuten, die in diesem Zoom-Call waren, weil einer hat nichts gesagt. Ja, Mann! Einer hat nichts gesagt und das ist für mich Charisma. Ja. Das ist, weil Leute verwechseln manchmal viel reden oder stattfinden wollen mit Charisma oder cool sein oder was auch immer. Selbstbewusstsein, ja. Selbstbewusstsein, der Typ, fucking, ich dachte mir, das ist der coolste Typ der Welt. Ich kann niemals so cool sein wie der, der war eine andere Liga-Coolness, er war in einem Zoom-Call, er hatte den Kalendereintrag, er hatte den Termin, er hatte den Blocker, er wacht morgens auf, geht seinen Kalendereintrag, hat Termine, geht da rein, lockt sich an, ist pünktlich, ist da, ist präsent und sagt nichts. Nichts. Eine Stunde lang, weil er nicht muss. Ja. Geil. Und man weiss genau, wenn man was gesagt hätte, was beschlossen worden wäre, was nicht funktioniert, hätte er was gesagt. Er wäre da gewesen, weil er war präsent. Nicht sagen, dass er sein Bild wäre angefroren, aber gut, vielleicht war er schlimm gestaltet. Nicht sagen, aber dann auch nach einer Stunde sagen, so Leute, ich muss es los, also ich bin dann draus. Einfach klar sagen, das ist meine Zeit und mehr aber auch nicht. Mehr habe ich nicht, mehr habe ich nicht zu geben. Ja, ich habe manchmal, ich vergesse sehr oft, mich auf laut zu steigen. Ja, das stimmt. Und dann ist der ganze Call schon für den Arsch. Gut, es kommt auch einfach zwei, drei Jahre zu spät, dieses Bit, aber dann ist man so direkt mit dem falschen Fuss im Call. Ja. Weil man so Gags macht am Anfang, um so den Tone zu setten und da, ich bin locker und cool und ich bin gar nicht nervös bei diesem Anruf, hallo, und dann merkt man, Stefan, man hört dich übrigens seit zehn Minuten nicht und dann macht man an und das ist direkt. Und wir hatten auch einen schönen Moment, der immer sehr entlarvend ist, deine Verbindung ist abgebrochen, was erstmal immer sehr witzig ist, weil das Bild einfriert, immer wirklich, wo man sich denkt, wie kommt der auf diese Grimasse beim normalen Reden? Der normales Reden und dann friert er ein mit so, was ist das für... Und im Hintergrund sind fünf Mexikaner und man denkt sich, wie kam jetzt die da, also die Momente, wo etwas einfriert, man fragt sich, wie kann das sein. Und dann kommst du wieder zurück nach sehr, sehr peinlichen fünf Minuten und dann stellst du die absolut fatale Frage, oh, was habe ich als letztes gesagt und alle gestehen ein, ich weiß nicht, niemand hat hier zuhört. Ja, du meintest nochmal wegen den Benchmarks. Also das Hauptthema des Calls. Genau, ja, irgendwie so, ja, das war so krass. Und dann, wo war ich gerade? Und dann sagt irgendwer, so nach einer halben Minute Stille, ein Wort, was das Thema des Calls ist. Ja. Ja, das war, also, ja, bitter. Schwieriger, eine bittere Niederlage. Absolut bittere Niederlage. Ich freue mich nur, dass, ja, ich weiß nicht, ich bin auch ein Fan von solchen Calls. Ich bin bei Calls auch, ja. Wenn die nämlich gut geführt sind, dann kann man da viele Sachen sehr, sehr schnell hinbekommen. Wie gesagt, ich plädiere immer noch für am Ende des Calls ein Voting war dieser Call. Zeitverschwendung, anonymisiert, ja, nein, zack, wunderbar, abhaken, hätte auch eine Mail sein können, weg. Wann dann einfach löschen. Ja, ich habe neulich, mein erster Impuls ist, nämlich eine Mail zu schreiben, immer. Wenn ich eine Mail bekomme, gar kein Hirnareal, bei keinem Hirnareal ploppt auf, ruft denjenigen doch an und klär das. Nee. Sondern mein erster Impuls ist, wütend in die Tasten zu hauen. Ja, es ist ... Und ich bin seit, ich gehe seit Wochen durch so einen komischen, so sagen wir mal, grob Wasserschaden-Thema. Und dann war ein Gutachter da und alles und so ein Riesending. Du, ich bin einer der wenigen Menschen, mit denen du wirklich über Wasserschäden reden kannst. Ich kenne das, das ist nicht mein erster Wasserschaden-Rodeo. Ja, aber gegen deinen Wasserschaden komme ich mir so wie so ein Idiot vor, der das alles zu hochkochen lässt, weil es nicht so viel passiert. Ja, ich kenne das, wenn jemand einen Schicksalsschlag hatte, dann sind alle anderen Schicksalsschläge plötzlich egal. Aber du kannst trotzdem mit allem zu mir kommen, jederzeit. Okay, das ist freundlich. Auch eine Pfütze. Okay. Was ist passiert? Nee, plötzlich, also wir haben eine neue Heizung bekommen und es tropfte dann plötzlich durch meine Decke die Wand herunter. Ja, das ist ja gar nichts. Das ist ja gar nichts. Das ist ja nichts. Hast du eine Ahnung, was bei mir los war? Bei mir hat das komplette Bad geflutet, drei Tage lang. Ja, ich weiß nicht, aber... Bist du getropft? Du hast gerade gesagt, dass es eine Safe Zone ist. Ich kann sagen, was ich will, unabhängig von deinem Schaden. Die Tür steht offen. Scheiße. Ja, und es tropft halt von der Decke. Und dann kam so eine Mail, dass ich das selbe, also dann... Oh, die Decke weint. Nee, ist auch egal. Wie gesagt, das war auch keine grosse Sache. Was hat das mit der Heizung zu tun? Die Heizung. Du meintest doch, ihr habt eine neue Heizung. Ja, der oben hat der Monteur dann vergessen, den Schlauch draufzustecken. Und deswegen tropft es von meiner Decke, hat dem Monteur einen Fehler gemacht, kann ja passieren. Ja, es wurde auch dann schnell behoben. Das ist ja gut. Bei mir wurde es nämlich nicht schnell behoben. Bei mir war es nach drei Tagen immer noch da, immer noch getropft. Aber freut mich ja, dass bei denen nichts passiert ist, wie schlimm ist. Ich habe auch gesagt, es tut mir leid, ich will mich nicht vergleichen mit deinem Chaos, was du da hast. Das war echt eine Scheiße. Das war echtiße. Das war echt was. Das tut mir auch. Das war echt was. Ja, tut mir leid. Tut mir leid, dass ich etwas gesagt habe. Boah, war das was, ey. Das war was. Das war wirklich was. Ja, ja, du, was war, aber was genau. Ey, das war was, ey, das sag ich dir. Ja, aber was war's? Das sag ich dir nicht nochmal. Okay. Da war was los, du, pf. Ja, aber du bist halt nicht. Du bist halt nicht konkreter als das, es bleibt halt super vage. Alles komplett, also runter, alles nur Bach runter. Ja. Es ist auch schwer, dir zu helfen, empathisch gegenüberzutreten, weil du halt nicht super vage bist, nee, das ist so krass gewesen mit so einer ... Boah, ey, wenn ich dran denke, wird mir schlecht, wirklich. Ja, wird mir richtig schlecht. Mittlerweile, vielleicht ist jemand eingezogen in meiner alten Wohnung, vielleicht müsste ich jetzt eigentlich hier den moralischen Menschen, den Bürger, den Mitbürger machen und einmal klopfen und sagen, wollen sie es wissen, in dieser Wohnung ist etwas passiert, wollen sie es wissen oder wollen sie in herrlicher Ignoranz leben. Aber kannst du so Zodiac-artige Rätsel oder so verschlüsselte, dechiffrierte Nachrichten an die Tür pappen? In Blut meinst du, in Blut geschrieben? Weiß ich, wo das jetzt herkommt. Weil meine Referenz war ja Saudi-Ak. Ich habe mehr Blut als einen Stift. Okay. Ich habe eher Zugang zu Blut als einen Stift. Wo ist der nächste Stift? Tinte, ne? Wo ist der nächste Stift im Umkreis? Was hast du für einen SR, für einen Stiftradius? Ja, Moment, aber Moment, Blut ist ja nicht einfach zugänglich. Da finde ich noch ein Stift noch zugänglicher. Klar, ich beiße mir in den Finger und dann streiche ich das auf dem Land.
Nein, man kann seinen Finger nicht beißen, weil das Gehirn dann sagt, nee, geht nicht, man kann sich nicht selber verletzen. Wie kommt man am schnellsten an Blut? Weil teilweise, manchmal habe ich wirklich das Gefühl, ist das deine Ernstnase? wenn ich ganz einfach Nasenbluten habe, wo ich mir denke, das war kein tiefes Popeln, das war beim besten Willen und ich weiss, wovon ich rede, das war kein tiefes Popeln, das war ein kurzes Anpopeln, das war höflich und die Nase sagt, alle schleusen offen, wie ich Dampo und ich bin, come on, das habe ich nicht verdient, Nase, das habe ich nicht verdient, Nase. Das steht nicht in Relation. Überhaupt nicht. Manche ist wie so eine Goldader, die genau an der Oberfläche verläuft. Und wenn du da drankommst, dann ist das Problem, ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Aber du musst genau wissen, wo die ist. Könntest du jetzt, das ist eigentlich eine geile Gameshow, oder? Blut ist gut, Blut ist gut, Ralf Tramitz, Christian Tramitz, Ralf Schmitz, Guido Kanz, Triplett, drei Moderatoren. Drei Moderatoren, drei Stunden Sendung, Barbara Schöneberger, vielleicht. Weiß nicht, ob sie aufhört. Je nachdem, ob wir die vierte Stunde bekommen oder nicht. Genau. Weil unser Konzept, dass jeder Moderator eine Stunde Sendezeit hat, steht über allem. Ja, genau, steht über allem. Und dann hast du da ein komplettes Line-Up von Gästen. Du hast Ulrich Wickert. Okay, ich habe Angst, diese Liste ist jetzt ... Wir haben Angela Merkel bekommen, sie ist da, sie ist das Comeback. Weil sie will das Buch promoten. Sie will ihr Buch promoten, sie will das Album promoten, sie malt jetzt so, sie ist da. Ja, wir haben ... Renate Schreinemaker ist da. Ja, wir haben Uli Zelle ist mit am Start. Wer ist Uli Zelle? Ist ein Schulfreund, Uli Zelle. Gute Leute. Und dann geht es darum, wer generiert als erstes Blut? Zehn, neun, acht, sieben, sechs, fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins, gut, go, go, go, go! So, wer als erstes Blut hat gewinnt, wie würdest du Blut an Blut kommen? Habe ich denn Props da oder nur meinen Körper? Habe ich was reingeschleustet mit dem Rasierklingel? Du hast technisch gesehen ein Ansteckmikrofon, wahrscheinlich. Ja, dann würde ich das nehmen, eine scharfe Kante und ganz längs meinen Arm. Längs aufsteigen. Um sicher zu gehen, dass falls, weil die Regeln wurden nicht klar genug erklärt, dass falls die Menge noch eine Rolle spielt, ich auch diesen Aspekt gewinne. Okay, wow, du gehst da ganz schön rein. Ey, wenn ich in einer Gameshow bin ... Aber jetzt angenommen, du hättest keine scharfen Gegenstände, du hättest nichts von Schärfe. Ich würde mir hier diese Pips, die Fingerpips abreißen. Also am Fingerbett aufreißen und dann so richtig tief rein. Meinst du, du kriegst da wirklich einen Tropfen raus? Moment, again. Blut, wer hat zuerst Blut? Nicht, wer hat zuerst einen Tropfen Blut? Wer hat zuerst Blut? Wenn ich da so einen Pips abmache und da ist ein bisschen rot und dann gibt er mir einen Taschenschuh und ich mache den einen Stempel drauf und da ist ein bisschen Blut, muss reichen. Muss reichen. Muss reichen. Ja, okay, wir haben jetzt halt noch zwei Stunden, fünfzig Minuten Sendung offen. Das ist ein Konzeptionsproblem, aber es wird nicht langweilig, weil in einer Dreiviertelstunde beginnt ein anderer Moderator zu machen. Genau. Und die Kandidaten haben im Laufe der Sendung immer weniger Blut. Die verlieren, das ist die Idee der Sendung. Blutspendeshow. Gut Blut, ja.
Mal gucken, was wir mit dem Blut dann machen.
So, das wird alles gesammelt.
Im Verkauf helfen, diesem sperrigen
Gemiss. Das wird alles gesammelt. Ne, mach dir keine Sorgen, das wird alles
gesammelt. Knick, knack.
Das wird alles am Ende noch gespendet.
Knick, knack.
So, und dann am Ende können wir gucken,
was wir mit dem machen. Wahrscheinlich ist Blut unbrauchbar, wenn es gemischt ist.
Wenn es komplett gemischt wurde, ist es komplett unbrauchbar. Unbrauchbar. Fuck, ey. Für jeden Wert. Fuck. So, anders als Mojito, der kriegt nur Wert, weil er gemischt ist. Und das dachte ich mir zum Beispiel auch bei den Uruk-Kai, weil du hast ja verschiedene Typen von Uruk-Kai, die zum Beispiel angreifen die Festung von Helms Klamm. Ich weiß, wer Uruk-Kai sind. Uruk-Kai sind die Super-Orks. Da sind Bilbis-Menschen gekreuzt mit Orks. Liebe ich ja natürlich die Behind-the-Scene, schaue ich auch immer an und dann stehen die natürlich unterschiedliche Rüstungen vor von den Uruk-Kai und dann ja, die haben nur Rüstung vorne, weil die würden niemals weglaufen. Die brauchen keine Rüstung am Rücken, weil die drehen ihrem Gegner niemals den Rücken zu und denkst dir, cool, das Worldbuildingbuilding, das gefällt mir, das ist geil. Und dann hast du aber eine besondere Klasse an Uruk-Kai, die noch krasser sind, das sind die Berserker, das sind die, die auf die Burgzinnen springen und mit ihren langen Zweihandschwertern um sich schlagen. Und die tragen gar keine Rüstung, weil die ultra krass sind, aber die haben einen Helm und der Helm ist so aufgebaut wie ein Helm.
Und bevor die sich den Helm aufsetzen, füllen die den mit dem Blut ihrer Feinde und setzen dann den Helm auf, sodass der Oberkörper komplett blutüberlaufen. Ein paar logistische Fragen. Die marschieren jetzt nach Helmsklamm. Wo kriegen die das Blut her? Also müssen die noch dann, bevor sie da eintreffen, sagen, pass auf, können wir noch mal kurz rechts ran mit unserem Heerzug, können wir noch mal kurz rechts ran. Nee, wir fahren auf der Fahrt auf der Stammze. Nee, aber pass auf. Okay, anhalten, blinken, rechts blinken, stopp, Schulterblick. Und jetzt, ich bräuchte nämlich noch Blut, weil ich hab den Helm, der ist extra so geformt wie ein Helm. Jeffrey, Jeffrey, Jeffrey.
Aber ich bin noch einer von den Berserkern.
Jeffrey, ich hab dich letzte Woche zum Berserker gemacht,
weil ich mir sicher war, du machst das gut.
Nein, aber ich hab ja Blut dabei.
So ist es ja nicht.
Aber hast du eine Ahnung, wie Blut in zwei Wochen aussieht?
Guck dir mal diesen Klumpen, Mann.
Ich setz den Helm mal auf, ich zeig dir, wie es aussieht. Der Helm, ich kann gar nicht durch die Augenschlitze gucken, der Helm ist viel zu weit oben. Ich habe den Helm wie so eine Kappe oben auf dem Kopf, der geht gar nicht über meinen Kopf drüber. Ich habe mir nicht genug Gedanken gemacht, ich gebe es zu, ich habe mir nicht genug Gedanken gemacht. Ja, da bleibt mir als Sturmbannführer nur eine Chance.
Ja.
Ich muss dich wieder zurücksetzen, du bist kein Berserker mehr.
Nein, nö, komm, nee.
Du kriegst eine Rüstung vorne, als Bestrafung, kriegst du eine Rüstung vorne.
Weißt du was, du als Bestrafung kriegst du eine Rüstung hinten.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen.
Weißt du was, als Bestrafung kriegst du geschützte Socken, erwärmte Socken.
Ja, dann gehe ich rückwärts in die Schlacht und dann?
Dann gehe ich halt rückwärts, greife ich rückwärts an, kein Problem.
Das ist kein Problem. Dann stecken wir dich in so ein gepanzertes Auto. Nein, nee, das ist Quatsch. So, letztes Wort. Ja, zwei Threads im Filmfirma sind aktuell offen. Ich schau mal nach. Oh, das waren so wenige, hatten wir noch nie offen. Null Likes. Genau, so, zurück zum Mail. Floni wollte lieber eine random Quiz, eine Blutgewinnungsshow pitchen, als diese Mail zu hören. Ist auch egal, jedenfalls, es kam dann zu diesem Schaden, den will niemand bezahlen. Und dann hat mir jemand zurückgeschrieben, nach Wochen von Gutachten und bla bla bla, ja gut, dann haben wir es ja jetzt. Ich glaube nicht, dass da eine Versicherung tragen wird. Aber es wurde noch keine Versicherung direkt kontaktiert mit diesem Gutachten, sondern, ja, ist egal. Und mein erster Impuls war wirklich, direkt wütend zurückzuschreiben, so, nee, das sehe ich anders, können Sie nicht das bitte, einfach mal jetzt eine Versicherung geben. Also das ist ja das Naheliegendste, erstmal zu fragen und nicht direkt aufzugeben, weil warum soll ich was bezahlen, wenn darüber mir Leute vergessen haben, den Schlauch aufzusehen. Und dann habe ich das abgeschickt, diese Mail, dachte mir, ja, jetzt wartet man halt einen Tag lang auf eine Antwort und dann antwortet man selber wieder viel zu spät und dann wird man wieder so ich werde dann auch immer aus dem Tag gerissen, wenn dann so eine Mail kommt zu einem anderen Thema, dann bin ich direkt da und dann habe ich einfach angerufen und das war das weirdeste, da habe ich diese Mail geschrieben, das wird auch zu verzweifelt so ja, ja, konnte ich mit leben, weil war ich auch und dann habe ich angerufen und er liest gerade die Mail und geht ran mit so einem, Herr Tietze, so war so, hat Angst vor mir, weil diese Mail so tough formuliert war, so hart. Und ich habe dann aber dann normal mit der gleichen Gefühlsregung, aber normal mit ihm gesprochen und es war alles geklärt. Und da habe ich wirklich darüber nachgedacht. Selbst, es heißt ja so, okay, antworte erst später, lass die Emotionen, let them sink in und dann denkst du danach darüber nach und rufst dann an oder schreibst dann eine Mail. Nein, man kann auch sofort reagieren, aber wenn man anruft und normal, weil geschrieben kann alles interpretiert werden, ist einfach so.
Aber wenn du anrufst, da kommen viele Emotionen mit und so, und dann merkt der, okay, es ist im ernsthaften Ansinnen und wir sind doch alle Menschen. Das war eine viel bessere Art, das zu klären. Es ist natürlich so ein kombinierter Angriff, dass du dir eine WhatsApp-Nachricht schreibst und dann wartest du, bis die blauen Häkchen kommen und dann rufst du an. Genau in der Sekunde rufst du an, in der du die blauen Häkchen siehst, sofort anrufen, dass du weißt, die Person liest gerade die Nachricht und in genau dem Moment hast du Stefan am Telefon, der einfach direkt rein, einfach zwei Angriffe gleichzeitig, das finde ich schon nicht schlecht eigentlich. Das ist ein Napoleon-Manöver, ne? Ach Gott, ja. Ich komme von der einen Seite, aber eigentlich komme ich von der anderen Seite. Lagen ist schon davor gemacht, aber ich finde auch, Kommunikation ist mittlerweile durch. Wir brauchen neue Kommunikationswege. Ich habe letztens eine Hotline gesehen, irgendwie so eine Kundenhotline von einer Firma. Und dann statt die Hotline und dann statt drunter und wenn das nicht klappt, dann und eine andere Nummer. Da dachte ich mir auch, Leute, was soll das denn? Wer von Anfang an sagt, das geht nicht. Ruf hier an und wenn das nicht klappt, hier. Warum nicht direkt bei der zweiten anrufen? Wenn Scheitern Teil der initialen Kommunikation ist, fucking burn the place down. Und vor allem, das war professionell gedruckt auf das Produkt. Irgendjemand muss doch sagen, Leute,
lässt uns das nicht wie komplette Vollidioten aussehen.
Das ist so ein Saft, steckt mir vor, man steht da so drauf,
und wenn der nicht schmeckt, trink eine Cola.
Wenn der nicht schmeckt, dann trink was anderes.
Nein, das sollte nicht
heile Kommunikation sein. Genau, bitte hier öffnen,
wenn das nicht klappt, Schere.
Schere, Schere, einfach alles ab.
Dann schneit einfach alles ab, dann funktioniert's nicht. Wenn das sein muss, dann war das erste eine doofe Idee. Nee, funktioniert nicht. Scheitern funktioniert nicht. Wir haben noch eine Instagram-Nachricht bekommen, bevor ich es vergesse. Ich kriege es auch nicht mehr zusammen. Aber wir haben ja die Frage in den Raum gestellt. Kommunikation mit der Community ist ja wichtig. Wir haben um juristischen Beistand gefläht, quasi gebettelt, quasi. Wir lagen auf dem Boden, wir haben mit den Beinen und mit den Fäusten gleichzeitig auf dem Boden getrommelt. Wie so ein Schneeengel. Wie so ein Stocksauerer. Blütender Schneeengel. Haben wir nach Hilfe gebettelt zum Thema? Ähm, Mobbing im Netz. Nein, Weihnachtsbaum. Ich habe einen Weihnachtsbaum entwendet im weitesten Sinne. Ich habe einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft, aber nicht bezahlt. Erinnerst du dich? Nothing. Weihnachts, okay, wow. Krass. Mittlerweile, deine Gedächtnislücken werden schneller, habe ich das Gefühl. Oder ich denke mir immer, dass du vielleicht das im Stream erzählt hast oder auch in den Outlets ich habe ja eine Nachricht be- Ja. Doch, das habe ich schon erzählt. Weihnachtsbaum, ähm, Gaslighting-Versuch. Baumarkt. Vielleicht hast du es einfach deiner Katze erzählt, kann auch sein. Nee, Weihnachtsbaum, habe dann aber gemerkt, der wurde gar nicht abgerechnet an der Kasse. Nun hatte ich den umsonst und habe auf dem Parkplatz vom Baumarkt überlegt, soll ich den zurückbringen, ja oder nein, habe mich dann für nein entschieden.
So, und dann habe ich gefragt, wie sieht das jetzt juristisch aus? Ich erinnere mich, das war die Geschichte, wo du den Currywurst-Mann, nämlich dem, der tut dir leid und dem gibst du Geld, an anderer Stelle klaust du aber und Santa Claus und Knecht Rübrecht sitzen da und wissen nicht, was sie mit dir anstellen sollen, weil du sowohl auf der Naughty als auch auf der Nice-List bist. Richtig, es war ein sehr verwirrendes Weihnachten für mich, weil ich nicht genau wusste, war ich gut oder schlecht.
Und ich habe diesen Weihnachtsbaum geklaut, dachte ich zumindest. Juristische Einordnung kam dann prompt aus der Community. Und zwar, also die Frage ist das Diebstahl. Wenn du merkst, ich habe etwas bekommen, ohne dafür zu zahlen, musst du das dann sozusagen rückabwickeln, wenn du merkst,
ich hab hier etwas bekommen, was ich gar nicht eigentlich hätte bekommen sollen. Und die Person
hat geschrieben, nein, das ist kein Diebstahl,
das ist alles rechtens, und jetzt,
ich geb's falsch wieder,
bin bei uns einig.
Man freut sich dann darum, überhaupt, aber okay.
Ja, ich hab das kurz überflogen
und die Hälfte vergessen, okay.
Und zwar hat die Person das so erklärt, der Wille zur Straftat und die Straftat fanden nicht gleichzeitig statt. Also erst habe ich was geklaut, wollte es aber gar nicht klauen an der Kasse und später wollte ich es klauen, habe es aber nicht geklaut zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und damit eine Straftat realisiert wird, muss der Wille und die Tat gleichzeitig stattfinden.
Für mich ist das aber nicht klar abgehakt.
Habe ich jetzt falsch wiedergegeben.
Ich habe es komplett falsch wiedergegeben.
Also, pass auf.
Das hat nichts mit Juristerei, mit Jus zu tun.
Für mich ist das so ein Venn-Diagram.
Und die Aktion, du wolltest nicht klauen, du wolltest zahlen, nimmst den mit. Und dann, wann ist es dir aufgefallen? Parkplatz. Da bist du noch in der Nähe. Ja, bin ich. Und das Event des Diebstahls fällt also mit der Absicht des Diebstahls zusammen. Eben nicht, also dieser Einsender, leeres Profilbild, kein Profilbild, kein Blauhaken, erste Nachricht, null Follower, kann auch sein, ja. Ich weiß nicht, wie Juristen aktuell so aussehen. Aber der meinte, nein, es muss gleichzeitig stattfinden. Was ja spannend ist, weil ich habe natürlich sofort überlegt, wie könnte man das ausnutzen? Also könnte ich sozusagen ... Naja, dann ist man raus, wenn man sagt, ich wollte es gar nicht klauen. Und dann sagt die Rewe-Mitarbeiterin an der Self-Checkout-Klasse, ah okay, gut, dann ja rechtlich können sie jetzt dann einfach gehen, ja. Naja, aber wenn deine Tat darauf Rückschlüsse lässt, dass du es auch klauen wolltest, wenn du etwas aktiv nicht bezahlt hast, obwohl du es eigentlich hättest machen sollen. Aber die holen einen Lügendetektor raus und dann sagen sie, ja okay, sagen sie für 9000 Euro kriegst du sieben bis elf Fragen. Ich habe aber nur sieben Fragen. Okay, wollten sie die Barilla Nummer drei kaufen? Wollten sie die Coke Zero kaufen? Ja. Wollten sie den Eisbergsalat klauen? Nein. Lüge. Warum? Wollten sie das Nasenspray kaufen? Ja, ich dachte, ich könnte Es ist ein Lliege. Warum? Wollt ihr Nasen-Break haufen? Ja, ich dachte, ich könnte den Lügendetektor überlisten, indem ich mir die Nase zuhalte. Herr Will, bitte, das ist albern. Das ist albern. Aber kann ja sein. Stimmerkennung so. Ja. Und hier müssen Zeugen ja dann so die Stimme erkennen. Und dann so, ja, sagen Sie mal, ich krieg dich. Krieg dich. Nee, so wie sie es normal sind. Quatsch, auch diese Gegenüberstellungen. Gibt es auch nicht. Gibt es das echt oder nicht, dass man dann wirklich dahingestellt wird und dann wirst du eingeladen? Wen laden die da ein? Also was sind, also okay, irgendwie ja, der hat mich ausgeraubt, der sah so aus und dann kommen zehn Leute, dicke Männer mit Bart und dann musst du sagen, wer, was sind das für Leute? Ja, an dieser Stelle möchte ich meine Lanze brechen für deutsche Filmschaffende, weil klar, vieles ist hier schlechter, so, viele Sachen guckt man nicht so gerne, Tatort, Polizeiruf, so, es gibt einfach viel Schrott, viel Trash, aber wir haben halt auch ein langweiliges, technokratisches, pragmatisches Land. Richtig. Es ist halt nicht so ein Showland wie die USA, wo du Gegenüberstellungen hast, keine Geschworenen, Lügendetektoren, Geschworene, wo du so Show-Trials hast. Also es ist alles abgefahren. Es ist nicht besser, klar, ich will da nicht leben, aber ich will das sehen. Aber bei uns ist einfach so alles so erprobt und pragmatisch und sinnvoll. Ja. Und dann ist es halt boring, ist es halt einfach boring, daraus so was zu machen. Deswegen, sorry, und ich möchte wirklich sagen, alle, die immer einen Tatort geschrieben haben oder einen Polizeiruf und er war ein bisschen boring, er hat ein Mitgefühl. Und deswegen, ich finde, man sollte das auch irgendwie am Anfang der Folge oder so einfach benennen mit einer Texttafel. Pass auf, Leute, wir arbeiten hier echt mit super drögen Sachen. Basierend auf langweiligen Realität unseres Landes. Viel Spaß. Viel Spaß. Und dann geht's los. Genau. Vielleicht auch diese Musik ein bisschen weniger catchy machen. Das stimmt. Weil die Musik suggeriert, ah, hier kommt ein Kultklassiker, hier kommt was Cooles. Jemand rennt durch dunkle Gassen. Und danach einfach nur wirklich kammerspielartig ein Verhör, wo nichts passiert, bis dann irgendwer einknickt mit normalen Methoden. Beim Verhör so, wollten sie zum Tatzeitpunkt in Einklang mit dem Willen zur Straftat oder kam der Wille zur Straftat nach der Straftat?
Tatort Weihnachtsbaum.
Es kann sein, also ich habe das komplett falsch wiedergegeben und er fangt jetzt nicht an, Verbrechen zu begehen, wo er sagt, naja die Tat,, ich stelle es mir so vor wie ... Ich glaube, wenn der Wille nach der Tat kommt, ist easy going. Wenn der Wille vor der Tat kommt ... Also angenommen, du rollst jetzt, sagen wir mal, ein Boot, so ein Boot auf einem Anhänger. Du hast ein Auto mit einem Boot, einem Anhänger hinter dir. Und du willst den umbringen, der hinter dir fährt. Dann fährst du einen Berg hoch und dann entklingst du das Boot, Anhängerboot und jetzt ist der Wille zum Mord, jetzt dauert es aber noch eine gute acht Minuten, bis dieses Boot, Anhängerboot, Kombo. In der Zeit denkst du, oh nee, will ich gar nicht. Genau, fährst weiter, fährst zu McDonalds. Sorry, I call Bullshit. Und zwar, deswegen geht das hier jetzt raus nach Köln, zu WBS Legal, nämlich zu Christian Solmecke. Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln. Ist Florentins Straftat. Ist es keine Straftat. In Klammern Fragezeichen, zick. Florentin klaut einen, Florentin nimmt, ist im Begriff, ein Weihnachtsmann zu kaufen, will ihn nicht klauen, ihm fällt auf dem Parkplatz auf, er hat den gar nicht bezahlt, eine Straftat.
Weil genau das meine ich nämlich, ich baue eine Bombe, deponiere die irgendwo bei einem Gleis und will den ICE 318 nach Koblenz in Luft jagen.
Programmier das und in der Zeit
dann gehe ich
zu meinem Therapeuten,
bespreche das,
denke mir, was eine Quatschidee.
Jetzt muss ich kurz
über mich selber lachen.
Das ist wirklich ein furchtbarer Quatsch.
Da haben sie recht. Und ich krieg's aber nicht mehr zeitlich hin, das zu stoppen. Weil der Bus zu spät kommt. Du stehst an der Bushaltestelle. So. Wir haben hier auch Aufnahmen. Ja. Aber Sie schauen hier aufs Handy. Ja, aber was soll ich denn machen in der Zeit? Ja, aber wenn Sie gerade versuchen, Leben und Tod zu bewahren, hier die Menschen zu retten, Sie schauen auf Ihr Handy. Ja, das geht ja Ja, natürlich. Sie können in der Situation nicht Candy Crush spielen. Wieso denn nicht? Sie wollen gerade den Tod von unschuldigen Menschen verhindern. Ja, aber ich bin mit dem Bus immer schneller da. Wenn der Bus nicht kommt, was soll ich denn machen? Da können sie ja nicht Candy Crush spielen. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass ich nicht die Absicht habe, Leute zu retten. Aber dann ... So, aber weißt du, was ich meine?
Ja.
Da ist ja vielleicht dann die Reuesetzung vorher ein und so,
und die Absicht zur Tat fällt nicht zusammen mit der Tat.
Mir fällt da kein Beispiel, aber ich glaube,
wenn der Wille zur Tat nach der Tat kam.
Und das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so leicht,
sich da Dinge zu finden.
Also wenn du ... Anderes Beispiel. Mir kam
jetzt, ich habe ein Paket bestellt.
Online-Shopping.
Dann habe ich da meine Sachen
rausgesucht, die ich haben wollte.
Die Sachen, die ich nicht wollte, habe ich
zurückgeschickt. Und dann kam einen Tag
später das gleiche Paket nochmal.
Und
das heißt, die Firma hat das
vercheckt. Die hat aus Versehen zweimal dieses Paket zu mir geschickt, ich habe nur eine Rechnung, ich habe nur eine Bestätigung und so, das heißt diese ganzen Sachen hätte ich theoretisch einfach verkaufen können und ja, wäre niemandem aufgefallen, stattdessen habe ich dann natürlich großzügig wie ich bin der Firma geschrieben, ey ihr habt mir das Paket nochmal geschickt. Und dann habe ich den zurückgeschickt.
Aber da wäre ja jetzt ja auch, die Absicht zum Diebstahl ist mir ja erst eingefallen,
dass es die überhaupt geben könnte, nachdem ... Wenn die es dir zuschicken, naja, naja.
Aber ja, es stimmt schon.
Ich habe auch einen interessanten Rechtsfall, und zwar wäre ich fast ermordet worden,
meiner Perspektive nach.
Okay. Also, und zwar, wir waren ja im schönen München, Bayern, wir waren unterwegs. Wir waren in München, ja. Wo ist die Haupte eingeladen, wo ist der Woman Bayern ein bisschen. Und ich bin ja in Bayern aufgewachsen und ich bin immer ein sehr nostalgischer Mensch, der gerne auch dann so Kindheitsorte besucht und so. Du wächst ja überhaupt nicht. Vielleicht kennst du mich auch nicht so gut, vielleicht hörst du mir nicht gut genug zu, wenn ich über mich persönlich mal rede. Und dann war ich im Wald, ja, in der Nähe von dem Ort, wo ich aufgewachsen bin, gibt es einen grossen Wald und da war ich früher auch immer unterwegs. Da habe ich immer meine Schauspielmonologe geübt, weil ich wollte ja Schauspieler werden, auf die Schauspielschule muss man Monologe üben. Und für einen jungen, aufstrebenden, aber sehr schüchternen Schauspieler stellt sich immer die Frage, wo soll ich
die üben? Weil ich will ja von niemandem
gehört werden. Und das sind ja, du denkst
ja, ein toller Schauspieler ist einer, der schreit
und zusammenbricht und fleht und heult
und so. Und er versuchst
natürlich, deinen Monologe, egal worum es geht,
immer möglichst dramatisch darzustellen.
Und das kannst du natürlich nicht im Kinderzimmer machen,
weil du willst von niemandem gehört werden.
Ich stehe mir gerade vor, so eine Mogli-artige Geschichte,
wie du nicht von Wölfen grossgezogen
wirst, sondern von Wölfen das Schauspiel Vielen Dank. hin. Und das kannst du natürlich nicht im Kinderzimmer machen, weil du willst von jemandem gehört werden. Ich stehe mir gerade vor, so eine Mogli-artige Geschichte,
wie du nicht von Wölfen grossgezogen wirst,
sondern von Wölfen das Schauspielen
beigebracht bekommst, weil du in den Wald
gehst, um deine Monologe zu üben und
irgendwann so ein Wolf zu dir kommt und sagt,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das muss
von ihnen kommen. Also wenn sie
die Gefühle nicht spüren, dann können sie sie auch nicht aus.
Dann können sie gehen.
Dann müssen sie die Gefühle spüren.
Wie Wölfe sagen, was du nicht spürst, das nicht passiert. Und dann, das ist dann mein Monolog letzten Endes, und ich wurde leider abgenommen. Und dann habe ich das da immer geübt. So, und seitdem fahre ich da immer gerne hin und gehe da nochmal so ein bisschen rum im Wald. So, und dann fahre ich da immer mit Carsharing-Auto hin, park da immer am gleichen Parkplatz, da gibt es Parkplätze im Wald an der Straße und dann laufe ich da ein bisschen durch die Gegend, fahre weiter, kein Problem. Da gibt es keinen Handyempfang, kein Internetempfang, nichts an diesem Parkplatz, aber bei Carsharing kannst du mit Bluetooth das Auto öffnen, weil bei Carsharing hast du manchmal keinen Schlüssel, sondern es geht übers Handy. Dann kannst du mit Bluetooth öffnen, weil du hast Verbindung zum Internet. Also kein Problem, fahre ich dahin, laufe durch die Gegend, komme zurück zum Auto, will es öffnen. Sie haben keine Internetverbindung. Sie können das Auto nur mit Internetverbindung öffnen. Und ich hatte keine Internetverbindung an diesem Ort. Es gibt kein Internet an diesem Ort. Und ich konnte das Auto nicht öffnen. Und ich stand mitten im Wald, kalt, Parkplatz, und ich konnte das Auto nicht öffnen. Und ich dachte, was, jetzt bin ich wirklich Schachmat. Du und deine ShareNow-Erfahrungen. Ja, vor allem ich dachte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, dass man immer das Auto auch mit Bluetooth öffnen konnte. Und aus irgendeinem Grund ging es nicht mehr. Ich habe das auch schon lange nicht mehr genutzt. Ohne Internet, so. Jetzt bin ich wirklich erledigt, weil selbst, also was mache ich denn jetzt? Du kannst ja niemanden anrufen, aber du hast keinen Empfang. Ich kann niemanden anrufen, ich habe keinen Empfang. Und selbst wenn ich jemanden anrufen könnte, das Auto steht ja in einem Ort, wo es kein Internet gibt. Niemand kann darauf zugreifen. Was soll jetzt passieren? Und ich stand mitten im Wald und dachte mir, okay, ich habe keine vernünftigen Schuhe an, ich habe keine vernünftige Kleidung, ich wollte nur so eine Stunde durch den Wald laufen, was mache ich jetzt?
Das ist eine Art Mordversuch.
Ich könnte hier wirklich zugrunde gehen.
Es ist von mir.
Ich könnte zugrunde gehen. Zum Glück hatte ich meine Powerbank dabei,
einen Rucksack dabei, Powerbank, Wasser,
ich hatte ein bisschen was dabei, und dann dachte
ich mir, okay, fuck, was mache ich jetzt?
Und dann bin ich einfach an der Strasse
entlang losgelaufen und wusste auch nicht, wie lange dauert das jetzt, wenn ich aus dem Wald komme. Ich bin immer nur mit Fahrrad oder Auto durch diesen Wald gefahren. Das ist ein großer Wald und du weißt einfach nicht, muss ich jetzt drei Stunden lang laufen, bis ich wieder irgendwo bin? Was passiert jetzt? Es wird langsam dunkel, es dämmert. Und ich denke mir wirklich, vielleicht war es das, das ist mein Ende, das ist mein Ende. Ich erfriere hier elendig an diesem Ort, bis ich irgendwann ankomme, aus dem Wald raus und ich habe wieder Empfang, Handyempfang und rufe beim Support an, beim Carsharing Support. Dass da jetzt ein Auto steht. Dass da jetzt ein Auto steht im Nichts und ich jetzt wirklich eineinhalb Stunden gelaufen bin, aus dem Wald raus, an der Strasse entlang und es dämmert wirklich gerade und ich jetzt auch die Entscheidung treffen muss, kann ich überhaupt noch zum Auto zurück, weil wenn es dann nicht offen ist, dann ist es stockdunkel, eiskalt und dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Dann war es Flo mit Flo und Team. Dann war es das, oder soll ich jetzt einfach hier weitermachen, soll ich mir hier ein Taxi rufen oder irgendwas, weil jetzt habe ich zumindest greifbar Internetkontakt zur Außenwelt. Und dann meint der Mitarbeiter so, ja, ja, okay, ich mache Ihnen das auf. Wie kriegt der das denn auf? So, und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, aber ich muss jetzt eineinhalb Stunden zurücklaufen. Sind Sie sich einhundertprozentig sicher, dass das Auto offen sein wird, weil ich kann sie dann auch nicht mehr anrufen. Ich muss mich jetzt wirklich zu hundertprozentig verlassen. Und es kann auch jemand damit wegfahren. Könnte auch jemand wegfahren, ist dann einfach offen. Und er meinte so, ja, ja, ich achte da drauf, ich gucke, ob sie wegfahren, ich halte das offen. Vor allem mein Vertrauen zu solchen Mitarbeitern ist leider so gering. Ja, weil ich war auch immer so ein ich bin schäbig, du willst einfach nur Feierabend machen, fuck it, du willst einfach auf Mindestlohnbasis, willst du Gronkh-Videos schauen und nichts machen, so kein Problem. Ja, und ich verstehe es, ich verstehe es. Und ich will sich da nicht selbst in diesem Job. Nee, und dann dachte ich, okay, ich kenne sie nicht, aber ich bin jetzt wirklich auf sie angewiesen, als Mensch in den eiskalten Wald zu gehen, anderthalb Stunden lang, es ist dann wirklich dunkel, wenn ich da bin, wenn das Auto nicht offen ist, dann habe ich wirklich ein echtes Problem. Kein Problem, passt schon, das Auto ist offen. Das lässt mich daran denken, dass die richtig viel Quatsch erleben. Ja, das denke ich mir auch.
Wenn seine Reaktion so ist,
weil plötzlich wird
ein Leben in deine Hände
gelegt. Er wird dich
gerade dann für dein Leben, zumindest dein Wohlbefinden,
verantwortlich.
Da geht es ja mit
in der Wallachei sein irgendwo
und möglicherweise nicht
am Tag mehr nach Hause zu kommen, da geht es ja um was. Und diese Nonchalant-Ness, dieses Typen, ist ja irre. Sie ist irre, sie hat mir aber auch ein bisschen Sicherheit gegeben, weil wenn der gedacht ist, oh fuck, scheiße, keine Ahnung, was sie macht. So jemand hätte ich gedacht, okay, der ist sich der Verantwortung bewusst. Der, okay, auch. Ich weiß nicht, wen man will in der Situation. Doch, ich will den nervösen, Okay, we got this. Ich will so einen ... Weißt du, wie dieser eine Typ, der bei Iron Man immer in der Zentrale, dieser eine Superhelden-Trope-Character, der immer sagt, okay, wir stehen das gemeinsam durch. Ja, ja, okay. Und da bin ich, habe ich mir gesagt, okay, ich vertraue Ihnen, ich gehe jetzt zurück. Ich gehe jetzt den kompletten Weg zu Fuß in meinen Latschen, in der Kälte noch mal zurück.. Dreh um, geh zurück und dann nach 20 Minuten denke ich mir auch, ja, aber wie kann der das denn aufmachen? Also, wenn da keine Internetverbindung ist oder irgendwas, wie soll das gehen? Kriegt der da das richtige Feedback von dem Auto, dass das offen ist oder was? Ist der sich da sicher? Und ich lauufe und denke mir, ist das eine gute Idee, soll ich nicht einfach umdrehen,
fuck it, irgendwie, dann habe ich halt
lange Miete oder was und dann muss ich, keine Ahnung,
fahr, lauf zurück,
du machst das jetzt einfach, lauf zurück,
wird immer dunkler, Podcast
auf meinem Ohr ist das einzige, was mich noch
bei Verstand hält, komm da
an im Auto und denk mir, okay, jetzt,
das ist es jetzt, mein Leben hängt jetzt
an diesem Auto,
das Auto natürlich, mir, okay, jetzt, das ist es jetzt, mein Leben hängt jetzt an diesem Auto. Das Auto, natürlich, noch offen. Aber offen. Setz mich rein, fahrlos, alles gut, alles gut gelaufen. Es war ein Abenteuer, aber ich denke mir wirklich, also warum kann der da hin, was haben die für eine Lasersatellitentechnik? Weil die so diese Elon-Musk-Satelliten da hinlenken. Ja, der wird dann so ausgerichtet, so das Auge Saurons.
Ja, so Doktor-No-artige, so James-Bond-Technik.
Weil warum kann der da connecten und ich nicht?
Also warum ... Generell, GPS, Internet, diese ganzen Wifi.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Was ist das alles für? Wellen?
Lo-Fi.
Weil manchmal kann ich Google Maps benutzen, obwohl ich keinen Handyempfang habe. GPS. So, dann ist da oben manchmal so ein Satellit. Dann denke ich mir, okay, mein Handy hat eine Satellitenverbindung, aber es ist kein Netzsatellit. Satelliten. Dann stelle ich mir eine Frage, wie funktioniert das? Aber dann muss ich mich nicht dazu zwingen, dass ich das an einem anderen Zeitpunkt nachhole.
Dein Gehirn sagt, die Zeit haben wir nicht gerade. Zeit haben wir nicht, fokussier dich, fokussier dich, fokussier dich. Dann denke ich mir, woher kommt denn mein Handyempfang? Hat mein Vater damals immer gesagt, das sind Satelliten. Ich glaube nicht, es gibt ja diese 5G-Masten, die dann von so Beschreibungstheoretikern und für alles verantwortlich gemacht werden. Die Masten, das sind Masten. Ja, ja. Also muss ich in der Nähe eines Funkmasten, wenn Leichen irgendwie gefunden werden, geht es auch darum, bei welchem Funkmast das Handy wann Kontakt hat. Trianguliert, ja, ja. Genau, wird trianguliert, um den Standort zu bestimmen. Und da, deswegen weiß ich nicht genau, Funkmasten ist, glaube ich, was anderes als Satellit, offensichtlich, aber dann manchmal geht GPS, dann kannst du Google Maps benutzen, obwohl du kein Internet hast. Manchmal kann ich es aber auch nicht benutzen. Und es heißt, GPS hat eine andere Wellenlänge oder was? Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, ob der da nochmal extra Zugriff hat oder irgendwie so, weil du hast ja auch keinen Notruf oder so, ist dann auch nochmal krasser oder so? Da kannst du plötzlich Notruf anrufen, obwohl du sonst nicht telefonieren kannst irgendwie, noch mal so ein Special-Ding, das ist wie so ein Nachtisch-Magen, so du kannst nicht mehr essen, aber Nachtisch geht schon noch, so das sind so andere Ebenen, so das ist einfach noch mal so, ich hab keine Ahnung. Vor allem kann er dann alle Autos gleichzeitig, also das auch jeder, weil du hast ja nicht, du willst ja nicht zum Supervisor durchgestellt, sondern du bist bei dem erstbesten Guy, Tim, gelandet und Tim konnte dann dieses Auto aufmachen. Kann der alle Autos von seinem Scheitern aufmachen? Ja, kann alles. Der kann alles. Aber das war echt, wo so Technik und Natur so aufeinandertreffen und wo mich das richtig in den Rücken bei, irgendwie es könnte auch sein können, dass ich keine Powerbank dabei habe,
mein Handy leer ist und dann wäre ich einfach am Ende gewesen.
Ich dachte mir wirklich, weil in meinem Kopf dachte ich,
dass dieses Auto nie wieder geöffnet werden kann
und irgendein Techniker mit einem Bus rausfahren muss,
um das händisch aufzubrechen.
Um dieses moosbewachsene Auto zu retten.
Ich hatte ja wirklich eineinhalb Stunden Zeit,
dass ich mir gedacht habe, was passiert jetzt, fahre ich? Ich dachte, ich sitze mit einem Techniker in einem Taxi. Das war meine Vorstellung. Ich hinten links, Techniker hinten rechts, Stille, kein Gespräch. Wir fahren durch den Forst, fahren da hin. Wieso muss der Techniker mit dem Taxi kommen? Ja, weil wir dann, und dann, hier, biegen Sie hier ab, biegen Sie hier ab, und dann, ah, ist das das Auto, ja, brechen auf, und dann, ja, nehmen Sie mich jetzt mit, und dann fahre ich mit dem Techniker wieder weg, mit dem Carsharing-Auto und das Taxi war anders. Gut, dass Techniker für dich in dem Kopf einfach komplett mittellose Menschen sind ohne Auto. Ich dachte, der kommt mit der S-Bahn an und trifft mich dann im Taxi und ich dachte mir, das ist wirklich... Was hast du für einen Podcast währenddessen gehört, während deiner Odyssee? Script Notes. Weil ich denke mir nämlich, spannend. Den höre ich immer in Bayern, den höre ich immer unterwegs. Ich frage mich nur, wie gut hast du zugehört? Weil ich kenne das nämlich auch, dass man so Panikmomente sich runterregeln will, indem man so ganz normale Podcast Podcasts in einer normalen Stimmung, da hast du John August und Craig Mason reden, entspannt über Filme und gleichzeitig ist dein Kopf in so einem Panik-Mode. Da frage ich mich auch, wie gut hört man dann zu? Ja, aber auf der einen Seite, rückblickend hat es sich total reingebrannt, irgendwie auch, was man da gehört hat und wo man unterwegs ist.
Und jetzt mittlerweile, immer wenn ich da diese Strasse fahre,
sehe ich den Weg an der Strasse und denke mir,
ach, da bin ich entlang gelaufen, da hatte ich Angst um mein Leben.
Aber ich hatte zum Glück zwei Paar Socken an.
Ich habe die Doppelsocke gemacht und da bin ich echt froh drum, rückblickend.
Da haben wir nie mehr im Leben eine Doppelsocke gemacht.
Doch, Doppelsocke ist super, also kann ich echt empfehlen.
Doppelsocken rein und dann ist es ja auch nicht mehr kalt. Wahnsinn. Ja, wow, wir sind froh, dass du hier bist noch. Ja, ich hätte es fast nicht geschafft zu unserer zweiten Show. Und was macht jetzt das mit dir, so ein Nahtoderlebnis? Ich denke natürlich schon mein Leben um und denke mir, diese Firma werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr benutzen, wenn man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann, dass man nicht irgendwo strandet. Aber nee, ich meine jetzt eher so fürs Leben, nicht so pragmatisch, dass du diesen einen Anbieter nicht mehr hast. Naja, die Miete war halt drei Stunden länger als war und ich dachte, soll ich das jetzt irgendwie reklamieren oder so? Das ist jetzt so philosophisch größer. Also was nimmst du jetzt mit dieser Nahtoderfahrung mit? Also jetzt irgendwie, willst du den Moment mehr geniessen?
Ja, ich habe mir schon gedacht, drei Stunden der Miete sind jetzt nicht, also habe ich es ja nicht genutzt, weil die können ja auch sehen in ihrem Programm, wann ich fahre und wann nicht.
Ja, aber willst du das Leuten sagen, eher mal sagen, dass du sie magst oder lieber Dinge machen, die du irgendwie gerne machst, aber aufsparst oder so?
Oder willst du mehr so im Jetzt den Moment die Natur wahrnehmen oder aufmerksam sein, Achtsamkeit? Nee. Nö. Ja. Ja, ähm, Leute, dann, ich oh,'s dann, glaub ich, auch jetzt packen, schon langsam,
weil ich muss noch los und ich hab morgen noch ...
Muss ich noch für die ... muss ich noch was vorbereiten für die ...
Für die Benchmarks.
Genau, ja, und für die Preso.
Gut, äh, dann ...
Ich will noch kurz noch mal sagen, jetzt so zum Ende, genau, also was wir besprochen haben im Prinzip, also dass es mir schon wichtig wäre, dass die Benchmarks, was Isabel gesagt hat, also dass wir, ja genau, sie hat sie ja schon gesagt im Grunde, ich glaube, dass wir noch mal festhalten, dass es wichtig ist, dass diesmal und dann wollte ich mich auch noch mal mischigt alles, genau. Und dann wollte ich mich auch noch mal bedanken, einfach für den Call und irgendwie das
kühle Gespräch und das alles so ...
Cool, alles klar.
Genau.
Dann haben wir es auch.
Isabel schickt alles rum und dann passt es und dann würde ich jetzt echt weiter.
Und wir gucken dann mal, dass wir ...
Wir müssen nicht gucken, wir haben es besprochen, wir müssen gar nicht gucken.
Wir schauen mal, dass wir da mal gucken, dass wir da mal ...
Nee, eigentlich, wir müssen weder schauen noch gucken, wir haben alles besprochen in
dieser Meeting, dafür war das Meeting da.
Es gibt kein Gucken und Schauen.
Ja, genau. Wer verschickt immer mit Mail rum, genau. Joshua schickt mit Mail. Gut, Meeting da. Es gibt kein Gucken und Schauen.
Wer verschickt immer mit Mail rum?
Alles klar. Ja, gut, alles klar.
Ciao, bis zum nächsten Mal.